turkey is marking three years since a
failed coup attempt against the
government of President wretch up type
err Diwan but many questions linger
about what actually happened we're
members of the country's armed forces
behind the plot was a rival of era
diwan's in exile whom turkey calls a
terrorist responsible while confusion
may hang over the failed coup its
consequences have been far clearer the
night of July 15 2016 was filled with
chaos and violence elements of the
Turkish Armed Forces launched an
operation to unseat president red ship
ty of air21 aircraft attacked government
buildings troops occupied bridges and
squares as many as 300 people were
killed on the 15th of July officers told
us it was a training operation but they
duped us we went out onto the streets
then the police came and we learnt the
reality when they detained US forces
loyal to air21 put down the coup his
government has since arrested tried in
jail tens of thousands of soldiers
teachers journalists and other public
servants many more have been removed
from their posts they stand accused of
supporting the attempt to take over or
at least disloyalty to the government
many more Turks at home and abroad still
support air21 but that's not guaranteed
to last a week currency skyrocketing
inflation and high interest rates have
shaken his grip on power relations with
the West are at a low point
then there's Ekrem imam aloo an
opposition figure and the next mayor of
Istanbul air21 held the post before he
ascended to the national stage a
parallel not lost on some voters
so much gum the president was mayor as
well
Akram Emmylou is following the same path
we will see better days no one can say
when those better times for heir to
one's opponents may come he survived the
bang of a coup attempt the whimper of
everyday politics may pose the bigger
challenge correspondent Orion Jones
joins us now with the view from Istanbul
Dorian how is this day being marked in
Turkey well it is the big event is a
national holiday democracy day as the
president has named it commemorations
have already started late last night it
was a big audio-visual show just down
the road from where I am recalling the
dramatic events of that failed coup but
the big events now start today this
afternoon there will be a major meeting
at the Ankara security headquarters that
was a center of heavy fighting which
many people died resisting the failed
coup attempt but the big event is this
evening at now the clothes Ataturk
Airport that was where earth one
returned back and he's returning back to
Istanbul on the night of the coup
effectively ended it as a rallying call
for his opponent his supporters to come
out onto the streets so he's going to be
a major major event all across the
country
Turkey's crackdown after the coup
attempt was widely criticized there
Dorian how has the country changed since
then well it's dramatically changed
there's been an unprecedented crackdown
in the country over 150,000 people have
been removed from their jobs civil
servants military personnel at the same
time over 70,000 people are in jail as a
result of that failed coup and the
crackdown still continues to this day
more people from the military are every
month removed from their posts and
prosecution still continue to this day
200 media all the organizations have
been shut down dozens of journalists
have been jailed increasingly opponents
and critics of the other ones say that
this is no longer about protecting
democracy but more about protecting
earth ones power so there is I think a
fatigue and this ongoing crackdown as is
there is mounting criticism
and the impact on Foreign Relations
because I mean a lot of this criticism
is coming from international powers
absolutely in many ways is at the fining
moment of Turkish Foreign Relations on
the night of the coup the first lis
international leader in contact with one
was the Russian President Vladimir Putin
is widely believed that Russian
intelligence tipped offered one on the
day of the coup that there was this a a
takeover looming on top of that the
Iranians were also closely in contact
with earth one that is in stark contrast
contrast with Turkey's Western allies
none of them contacted earth one on the
night of the coup and in the weeks
following very few for Western leaders
or Western officials visited earth one
in support that is in contrast with the
Russians and the Iranians and to this
day that is still feeding into this
distrust with in Ankara of its Western
Allies there's a feeling that there was
indifference if not outright complicity
in that failed coup and that continues
to color and Turkey's relations both
with its allies and what many people see
is Turkey's right our rivals GWS Dorian
Jones in Istanbul thank you